all's that I'm up to you this way Nancy
I did she speak to you like this about
positivity and about my mom reinforced
knowledge my mom reinforced you don't
start things and not finish them you
don't quit
there's nothing that comes out of
quitting besides knowing that you didn't
finish we finish everything you started
finish it if you're gonna do it do it to
try and be the best not be better than
other people be the best for you if
you're in school and you're going to
class I'm not asking you to get straight
A's I'm asking you to get the best grade
that you can possibly get give me a
hundred percent all the time and I'm a
happy mother when you half-ass me I'm on
yes mom I want to do this I wanna I want
to play baseball well then you gonna
play my mom like that no more then why'd
you start the season because I thought I
wanted to do it then you gonna finish
the season
you don't quit there's other people that
invested time and energy into you you
don't just quit on people but I don't
want to do it finish the season mom I
want to swim then you gonna finish swim
it didn't matter what I did I was never
allowed to quit so now in anything I do
when I pick it up a say i'ma start it I
got to finish it it all don't work it
all late the best hmm it all ain't
knocked out the park but I walk away
saying I finished it I did it I did it
right now I've been boxing I saw I saw
you working i will Rico Verhoeven I'm
fuckin first of all very strong kicker
okay
good guy but I starting jeans I started
it and I said why am I doing this I'm
not gonna be a professional fighter I'm
not trying to be a amateur fighter I'm
gonna begin to shape all right don't
start getting shaped I said yo so much
that don't know about the sport I at
least want to make sure that I'm paying
homage to the people that do this for a
living by really understanding and
learning it
you know what I'm gonna get a real
trainer I'm getting some real people to
show me everything so when it's all said
and done and I look back after my
training I can go I gave it 100% and
look at how good I got look at what I'm
a product of a spar I go getting really
yeah yeah just to feel it so I can say
it you know well sparse Bryan Callen is
this serious no it's me yeah that's me
come on that's me
dude that's me it's getting it to look
at this who is teaching you uh his name
is Biggs he's in Atlanta
that's me learn I had a turtle shell
within punches but you know he's a
former Golden Glove guy really good to
you were in a cup and everything what I
was at the sparring session when I'm
like real tired
damn yeah I got touched I got my ass
whipped in every couple times
worried about that all good now cuz I'm
not I don't go crazy we headgear and you
but I'm not in there with guys that are
trying to hurt yes I'm not in there was
touching guys that have no concept of
reality yeah or control like they're
they're just helping me understand right
here's why you have to keep you Anna
that is a problem with celebrities
trying to spar like if you try to like
you know that's why Mickey Rourke
started getting all that facial surgery
I'm serious he's sparring James Toney
Jesus that's just just not a smart James
told he's a mean man and it's just not
you can't like I don't I don't go in
that space have you ever seen James Tony
talk shit boys bars and there's some of
the most entertaining thing you'll ever
find on YouTube he's just he just won't
shut the fuck up beating your ass he's
talking shit that's that's bitch bitch
oh shit that's risky that's her and he's
one of the best defensive fighters ever
so he's really difficult to hit he's got
that she'll go most freshmen day in the
world yeah how the gods got any Mikey
I'm sparring with Mikey Mikey hit me
with three punches I thought I thought
Mikey literally had like six arms this
is a true story
listen I said I don't know would just
habit
but I thought I had my hands up in the
matter where I put him he just tapped me
he lets me feel it but not to where I
might getting knocked out but I
understand now movement I understand
pivots I understand shoulder protection
and that's my goal my goal is just
understand cuz I can't do anything
halfway okay have you trying to fight
somebody nope right nope I just want to
say that I did it and I learn and I can
move and I look the part cuz I put time
into it
well as you learn it too as you watch it
you still get trained then you start to
look at a guy like a Terence Crawford or
alumina chenko and you go oh now I
appreciate what you're doing cuz before
you'd see like oh yeah I beat that guy
up oh yeah he knocked that guy out but
then you see like how he ducks under the
left and fires back with the right you
know Jesus this is precision it's insane
yeah the the respect that I have people
that do that on a day to day is through
the roof yeah yeah yeah and people that
fight are in the most amazing shape in
the universe yeah you're in the most
amazing shape ever to move get hit for
three to five minutes around come back
do it come back do it and these fights
go on and on and on I take my hat off to
you
yeah you get three rounds out of me I'm
breathing out my butt I don't know where
the air is coming from I'm searching for
it it's a crazy way to make a living to
my yes in your brain thank God I don't I
didn't have to go down that route and
you know to those that do just make sure
you just put your body first like you
said it's it's hurtful when you see the
damage that it can cause yeah we were
talking about that earlier like seeing
guys as they start to deteriorate and
it's hard because nobody wants to tell
him that either every I want to tell him
they got one more good fighting them and
let's maybe at the end of the year then
we'll decide but right now we're gonna
train hard and my stuff it's hard too
because there's no options they don't
once you've established yourself as a
professional fighter and you don't have
an exit strategy you don't know what to
do you know now at least thankfully
because of the internet guys are getting
podcasts and they're starting doing
commentary shows and they're talking
about fighting and the positive you just
smile
positive that's the positive within the
internet there is positive you just
don't you just don't hear it celebrate
it as much well dinner is very positive
for me I mean this is the show we do on
the Internet I mean all not just podcast
but YouTube videos and also information
I know more because of the internet than
I ever would have without it there's not
a doubt in my mind a more educated more
aware person I want the Internet
yeah you can the things that you're able
to find and search and I mean like you
said you're you're able to self-educate
yeah at a very high level these are the
goods yeah we're talking about the goods
so when you talk about positive Kevin
how are you Ben yeah are you always like
that it's this it's the things that I
look at that are so easy you're not